♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
Today is Halloween,
so if you like jump scares,
ghouls, and goblins,
then you just have to wait
eight more days.
[ Light laughter ]
Until that.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden early voted
over the weekend in Delaware
because people his age
do everything early.
Voting two weeks before
the election, dinner at 4:30.
Hell, his luggage is already
packed for Christmas vacation.
[ Light laughter ]
That's right.
President Biden voted
over the weekend,
and in the interest
of bipartisanship,
he voted for everyone.
[ Laughter ]
"I like them all.
They're all good fellas."
[ Light laughter ]
Tesla's CEO Elon Musk last week
completed the $44 billion deal
to take control of Twitter.
And meanwhile, a lot
of his customers are still
trying to take control
of their Teslas.
[ Laughter ]
After completing the purchase of
Twitter on Thursday,
Elon Musk sent a tweet directed
at the social media company's
advertisers
and said the platform
"obviously cannot become
a free-for-all hellscape."
No, but it could stay that.
[ Laughter ]
During last week's
Pennsylvania Senate debate,
Republican candidate
Dr. Mehmet Oz said
that he thought the decisions
about abortion
should be left up to
"women, doctors,
local political leaders."
Though to be fair,
in some cases,
that local political leader
may be the father.
[ Laughter ]
Just statistically...
President Biden is reportedly
considering a plan to
use Guantanamo Bay
to house Haitian migrants.
Unfortunately
he's going to have to wait
another few days
to move them in.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, yesterday was
National Candy Corn Day,
which makes today national
"there's still plenty
of candy corn day."
There is only one week left
until the midterms.
Said Biden,
"Um, cocaine is legal?"
President Biden
yesterday suggested a tax on
oil and gas companies if they do
not increase production,
because if anyone's concerned
about energy prices,
it's the guy who probably keeps
the thermostat at 78.
New York governor Kathy Hochul
is set to hold a rally
on Thursday with
Hillary Clinton.
"Are you sure
that's a good idea?",
said Hillary Clinton.
President Biden spoke today
in Florida about
the importance of
Social Security and Medicare,
while Republicans
promised seniors
they'd just give them
that pool from "Cocoon."
A very, very fresh reference to
the film "Cocoon."
The New York City Council
last week
passed the so-called
Rat Action Plan
that aims to reduce
the number of rodents
within the five boroughs.
I guess they didn't have any
luck with their previous plan
of piling as much garbage
on the sidewalk as possible.
Come on, guys!
Whose plan was that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Was -- Be honest.
Did a rat give you that plan?
"Uh...
he was a little fella."
CDC director
Dr. Rochelle Walensky,
over the weekend,
tested positive again
for the coronavirus.
So, as per CDC recommendations,
she's taking a half-day.
In a recent interview,
singer Kid Rock said that
he would like to
have a beer with
former president Barack Obama
despite not liking
his policies or voting for him.
In fact, Barack Obama doesn't
even need to be there.
He'll just take
that beer, please.
Utah Senator Mitt Romney
posted a picture yesterday
on Twitter of himself
dressed as Mario for Halloween,
because the scariest thing
he could think of
is a foreigner
taking our plumbing jobs.
A man in South Africa recently
broke a Guinness World Record
by doing 19 consecutive
backbends in one minute.
Said the man, "Uh, right, yeah,
setting a world record.
Uh, yeah, that's what
I was trying to do."
[ Laughter ]
If you're wondering
what that joke means,
Mike Scollins wrote it.
Just work backwards from that.
And, finally,
Netflix's ad-supported plan
will launch this week
for just under $7 a month,
though it will be
free for everyone on
the dad-supported plan.
Somehow, that's a dad joke
at the same time.
"Are you still
on my dad-supported?"
Literally, like, what my dad
would call me up and say.
"You know they're
doing ad-supported.
Not you, though.
You're on the dad-supported."
President Biden criticized
the GOP yesterday and said,
"This ain't your father's
Republican Party."
Yeah, this one definitely feels
more like your uncle's.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden also said
that next week's midterms are
the "most important election
of our lifetime,"
and that's saying something,
coming from a guy who, maybe,
voted for Lincoln?
[ Laughter ]
President Biden warned yesterday
that Republican
Senator Rick Scott wants
to cut Social Security
and Medicare, and added,
"Hot damn, boy!"
By the way, using the phrase
"Hot damn, boy,"
instantly qualifies you
for Medicare.
[ Laughter and applause ]
At a campaign stop in Wisconsin,
Republican Senator Ron Johnson
said that he is not sure
if he will accept the results
of next week's
midterm elections, and added,
"Do Democrats have something
up their sleeves?"
Have you met Democrats?
They famously have nothing
up their sleeve.
[ Laughter ]
The best they can manage is
a quarter behind the ear.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
just 10% of voters
under the age of 40
strongly approve
of President Biden,
but mostly because people
under 40
don't really feel
strongly anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Dave, your house is on fire!
"Alright, man, I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
Agriculture
Secretary Tom Vilsack
told reporters yesterday
that the country is facing
a turkey shortage.
Oh, no!
You mean we might not get
to have
the world's driest meat
this Thanksgiving?
What's next, a shortage on the
raisins that ruin stuffing?
[ Laughter ]
Under a new pay transparency law
that took effect yesterday,
New York City employers
are now required
to disclose salary ranges
in all job listings,
which was a humiliating way
to find out Wally makes more
than me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A fire broke out early yesterday
at New York City's
Museum of Natural History
and took about an hour
to contain.
It took so long because none
of the rescue personnel
could figure out where they were
on the free map.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Starbucks will begin offering
its holiday drink cups tomorrow.
That story again --
tomorrow marks the start
of the war on Christmas.
"Plain red?!
[ Laughter ]
Do Jesus and Santa know
about this?!"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to new reports,
staff morale at CNN is
at an all-time low
as the network undergoes
a cost-cutting overhaul.
In related news, get ready
for the new season of...
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke last night
about the upcoming
midterm elections and said,
quote, "In our bones,
we know democracy is at risk."
And you know the president is
old when he gets his best intel
from his bones.
Ah, knee's acting up,
I feel a veto coming on.
President Biden urged voters
in his speech last night
to stand up for democracy and
said that Americans don't settle
political differences, quote,
"With a riot or a mob
or a bullet or a hammer."
We don't?
Because if not,
that's a weirdly specific list.
That's like if your wife asked
if you were cheating
and you said, "I don't even
think Rebecca's that sexy,
and I certainly wouldn't meet up
with her
at the Hotel Radisson Airport."
I put all the word
in a different order.
I wanted to see if it worked,
if you put them all
in a different word.
That's how you say it, right?
The Hotel Radisson Airport.
Alex -- he's our director --
can you just cut it up
and move all the words around
in post?
Problem solved. [ Laughs ]
In a new interview, Georgia
Senate candidate Herschel Walker
said that he has a better résumé
than Former President
Barack Obama.
Really? It's better than
Former President Barack Obama?
The only thing your résumé has
that his doesn't is typos.
CNN released a new poll
yesterday that suggests
Democrats may be facing
an enthusiasm problem
ahead of next week's
midterm elections,
which explains this here
sticker.
Former President Trump is
reportedly considering
the two-week stretch after
the midterm elections
as a window to formally announce
he's running for president
in 2024.
Oh, right before Thanksgiving?
Awesome.
Are you also gonna announce
that Aunt Lisa and her friend
aren't just roommates?
Elon Musk tweeted yesterday,
quote...
For instance, it could mean
you're the president.
SpaceX this week launched
its Falcon Heavy,
which is the most powerful
rocket in the world,
but I don't know how safe it is,
considering SpaceX is, I guess,
Elon Musk's third priority.
Who starts a space program
in their spare time?
NASCAR driver Ross Chastain
qualified
for a championship race
over the weekend
after performing
a wall-riding maneuver
that he claimed to have learned
from a Nintendo GameCube
video game as a child.
Even crazier, Denny Hamlin moved
into fifth place
after throwing a red shell
at the driver in front of him.
Two chefs in Boston recently set
a Guinness World Record
by assembling a sushi roll
that was over seven feet wide.
Now for the sad news.
[ Laughter ]
We realized the real problem
with that joke
is Shamu died like 20 years ago,
right?
[ Laughter ]
Don't eat other sushi.
And finally Dunkin' Donuts is
now offering its holiday menu
which includes a pancake
Wake-Up Wrap
that's filled with eggs,
American cheese,
and sausage or bacon.
The part they don't tell you is
where you'll wake up.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
♪♪